[Musik]
hartz4 eine krankenversicherung für alle
oder den mindestlohn das kind in
deutschland jeder aber warum gibt es
diese idee
sie sind das ergebnis der
wirtschaftsordnung in deutschland der
sozialen marktwirtschaft in einer
vollkommen freien marktwirtschaft ohne
reiniger für des staates gäbe es diese
dinge nicht denn in einer freien
marktwirtschaft richtet sich das
wirtschaftsleben nur nach angebot und
nachfrage bei dabei aber nicht alle über
die runden kommen unterstützt der staat
in der sozialen marktwirtschaft gezielt
er hilft zum beispiel arbeitslosen oder
legt untergrenzen für löhne fest ein
blick zurück im jahr 1948 ist der zweite
weltkrieg erst wenige jahre her
die folgen des krieges sind noch überall
sichtbar der ökonom alfred müller armack
arbeitete damals als staatssekretär
unter dem früheren wirtschaftsminister
ludwig erhard müller armack wollte eine
wirtschaftsordnung schaffen in der alle
bürger vom aufschwung nach dem krieg
profitieren konnten die soziale
marktwirtschaft
sie sollte frieden und stabilität in
deutschland sichern ludwig erhard
übernahm die idee für seine politik und
machte müller max konzept bekannt
seitdem gilt der begriff soziale
marktwirtschaft als der ausdruck mit dem
man das wirtschaftspolitische system in
deutschland beschreibt ohne funktioniert
sie ein beispiel die ungleichheit bei
einkommen messen statistiker mit dem die
nico effizienten je höher der jeanny
desto größer ist die ungleichheit vor
der umverteilung liegt dieser in
deutschland bei 0,49 also etwa so hoch
wie in den usa
nach der umverteilung durch steuern
renten und sozialhilfen liegt die
einkommensungleichheit in deutschland
deutlich niedriger bei 0,29
ein indiz dafür dass die soziale
marktwirtschaft ihr versprechen erfüllt
einige kritiker sagen allerdings dass
die soziale marktwirtschaft nur noch ein
politisches schlagwort ist in den
letzten 30 jahren ist die
einkommensungleichheit nämlich gestiegen
wie man hier sehen kann liegt der jeanny
heute höher als noch 1990
deshalb stellen viele die frage ist die
wirtschaft in deutschland noch sozial